it is being said and you can tell us
from your perspective it is being said
that these elections compared to five
years ago are fairer and freer there are
more opposition candidates there's more
debate authorities wanted of course to
demonstrated elections free and fair the
best elections ever but it's absolutely
not the case the only difference is that
asks political party people's Freedom
Party just the real opposition for the
first time allowed to participate in
elections we fighted for that fought for
the decades that for the first time will
participate but despite of the effect
the whole system the whole environment
said set up by the circus in Russia is
absolutely doesn't correspond to you to
do to the watch free and fair and are we
expecting just also the result would not
be credible because of the simple reason
the administrative pressure on on
candidates administrative pressure now
just saw waters and prepare preparation
for falsification taking place and now
just we see a lot of reports on the
region's when the ready people already
noticed sand so-called curse cells when
people and the buses moving from one
voting station to the other the same
people working for several times that's
already the case and many other many
other problems we already see but Russia
came to the crossroads and I think just
majority of Russians unfortunately don't
understand that that is only tomorrow
and year after they will understand that
Russia moving either to to a
totalitarian back back to the Soviet
Union totalitarian regime or just
restart slight changes if a position
real opposition in the parliament just
changes will start we hope just our
people waking up and water proc
appropriately and the level of support
will be such such a level that
authorities would not be capable to
falsify to make a fake results announced
next morning well well do you see mr.
Kazan of trouble on the streets again
like five years ago if people do
perceive the results not to be credible
this time we don't expect these
absolutely not after last elections you
know the President Putin the whole
TM created the special pressure on
opposition and they made a number of
cases I was a violation cases against
the position and people are scared
people skate just to to demonstrate to
demonstrate on the streets these days
but I think soon or late in any case in
any case we'll have changes we'd like
those changes over to achieve through
constitutional manners relations that's
why we believe that this day this day is
very important very important for us
otherwise we're moving to the to the
absolute the wrong direction and who
knows maybe that last last elections
which in a normal environment will see
what will happen because of people
people angry on authorities and the
United Russia will get much less than
ever people would like changes
authorities seems to be are not prepared
for that we'll see what level of
falsification we will have next morning
are you scared mr. Cazenove from you
know we've seen you on the Internet
seemingly stitched up in a in a sex tape
seeing you in the the crosshairs of a
sniper's rifle and we know what has
happened to other opposition leaders
yeah that's there's the case
unfortunately for for many months I was
followed pro-kremlin organizations a
special team they followed me everywhere
not only in Moscow but everywhere in the
regions they tried to block my meetings
with people they tried to arrange a
violent violence against me in your
physical violence and of course that is
the secret services of course going
around and creating illegal films and
illegal search etc etc everything we
press on our activists too many of them
under pressure in regions and it's quite
difficult to protect them against this
pressure and authority 7 not shying just
to demonstrate it just creating a cases
of pressure so that other people will
see that that opposition is not allowed
and I thought not normal from their
perspective mr. Cazenove one last
question I mean II left scratching
head as to why mr. Putin remains so
popular given the dire economic
situation in Russia mr. Putin is not so
popular as reporters majority of people
think that because of the the situation
there during the decade no single other
politicians could appear as independent
could create some kind feeling of
alternative people are afraid that if
not poaching that there will be some
kind of house disaster that's why they
hate Putin but continue to believe it's
better put him to stay let's change
something else that's why just where the
deadlock we cannot get out of this
problem but I believe that people
started to wake up and today there were
lot since illogical posts last is
illogical polls predicted for us for
people's Freedom Party as a ten percent
of support we'll see what will be a bit
tomorrow ten percent of course it's not
50 but ten percent that's a lot there's
already 78 million people in Russia
that's something I think that changes
will start in this case